>> I think it is obviously India's destiny
to become a superpower.
The whole infrastructure, the whole culture,
the whole development
we've seen in India predestines India to become
a superpower.
And I think it is for the Indians to start
believing in themselves, in
believing that they can, not only get India
right, but help India
contribute to getting the world right.
So I think getting involved in issues of climate
change, getting
involved in issues of poverty, getting involved
of issues of governance
at the global level, I think it will demonstrate
India's leadership in
a multiplicity of areas and give birth to
this superpower of India.